good job the bow sweat now
it's a beautiful day gonna burn
that
twas the night before Christmas in vault
111 now dwellers were staring for they'd
all gone to heaven the freezers were
emptied of ice cream and bread and
filled with the frosty remains of the
Dead when out of the blue arose such a
clatter that radroaches swarmed to see
what was the matter out of the vault
climbed an old man in red and Oh have we
mentioned his family are dead his beard
was white his wrinkles were deep he just
woken up from a 200-year sleep with a
spring and his staff and some toys in
his bag he rode through the wasteland on
a red-nosed rad stag come codsworth but
hancock now piper and Kure come royal
dog me and show them your fury we must
ride through the night to Diamond City
where they really love baseball and
think since a shitty and so the lone
Santa Claus rode with his crew with
pockets full of tape copper and blue he
knocked on the door of the big baseball
stadium with the night sky behind him
agreeing with uranium he crept through
the town with a quietest feet as the
chapel on perpend the shop of the meat
then a sudden noise made him grab his
bazooka but it was only the noodle but
sweet put up a tree and he put up some
lights though he couldn't make sure that
their Christmas was white he put out
some presents for all of the dwellers or
the children and ladies and robots and
fellows he's a cow skull for Timmy and a
bone saw for Elvis and a dog ball for
Simon with a rib cage and pelvis some
cement for Jemima a grenade for Elise
and lisas been bad so she gets
antifreeze when he'd emptied his sack on
the whole population and we came to the
end of this festive narration he
finished his gifting and boy what a
thrill when he heard the security
intruder shoot the kill
today's Christmas whole friggin